Hmm
again
I've
done it for you for
1 year 8 for 1 year
I can still do
it If it's eu, the result will be 3 in the next competition If it's
3 stars, that's all Oh,
if it's this rally site, it's still
ah pane nn nn
voodoo
[music]
Uchi 2 nn
voodoo
yep
[music]
hmm I like
it
I haven't heard that you've been fired.
And a
j
But Mitsufuji Bank is strict.
Even Mikoto, who was said to be vibrating,
can't call it that.
ni
Pakuchiin
th
I wonder if it's already over
Koi
yes yes yes
offer to this
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] The
call I received that day was an
offer from the manager of Business Team 3 Light Beverage
This Bud life wasn't over yet
I'm not a child, I'm stuck
[music]
Ah, I'm
ejaculating
pa
Yeah,
I mean, I've been a player in the first place, but
why did I wear a suit and a tie
?
A little matcha,
you're
a lifesaver.
If you're going to come on your own, do your best with the
rhizomes from the first day
!
It's Takanori-kun
, Shiratori-kun,
if there's anything you don't understand or have trouble with
, you can always ask.
Good morning, are you going to the
production area
again until morning?
I don't know if the carpenter didn't return the
oppo, so you're here.
Then it's too early to talk about it. I
'll ask you, the top sales performer in our company,
to
follow him.  Local cider
Have you been listening to craft b since 10 years ago
?
I'm a newcomer, please
guide me 1 Eh
Shiratori 3 I'm looking forward to working with you 3 I
'm a
newcomer and you?
He went to Kyoto,
Hawaii, and he doesn't think it's a
bad thing.
Sounds and early loss. Greetings from the company.
Practice starts at 4 o'clock.
Isn't it
strange that
I'm called as a bird player
?
4 big tits s J.League has changed, but
isn't it at the bottom?
Swim Good match play of the pair is the result
I don't know the job or the bird
I don't play doubles I see.
That's a shame.
I don't
know, hey, hey,
what's in that big power
?
It's crazy, my
mother
told me that I wore a necktie to work for the first time Who did you ask?
Nice to
meet you No, the king in his later years is
open Ah
, if you hold jazz, you'll have a hijab in your diary Army Didn't you ever have a diary
ARMY?
Bow tie-kun, who is rumored to be a singles
player,
is learning the fun way of using Sancha.
Under the person,
doubles of
doubles, I haven't done it, it's
given me
happiness  I'm dizzy because
I'm 19 yards?
I don't want
to
prove
that I'm wrong.
Come on
, I guess
you don't want to play doubles, so go
ahead
and beat me in singles.
It's fine, but
I'm the one who wins
.  ove
all play
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I thought yeah yeah yeah
it was
voodoo
wonder
[music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah  That's
not what I mean, I'm observing in the early
stages.
From the other person's point of view, it feels like their own movements are being predicted,
so if you're a
Psychic type, you
can say that he's good
at foreseeing people's movements in the demon world
, such as
eye movements and body orientation.  There are many other things
that you can predict the next move from there
.
The difference between the
elevens The fact is that the extra work becomes a powerful weapon The wearer has a lot of elements to bet on
Shiratori's ability is originally more effective in doubles A
single starter
There is no room to cover when you lose a bet
Dandan Ira
Benten
What is it?
I got my soul now,
so 5
tame I'm selling the selection after purifying it right away It's
okay, I'm
persistent
[music]
I'm going
home Shah
I need to be unreasonable to that point If I just
give up and lose the surgery, I'll
lose If that's the case  I'll take all of them Ah, you should give up
and pair with me
Breakthrough power that pushes through with power and
defense that reacts to the ball I
think it
's simple There's also a flower side It's
hard to do
Ai
Tecchan
[Music]
[Applause]
Stand up and it's
over  I don't know, it's
from here
[music]
yeah yeah yeah me this rally will continue
I
remember
the r market
Come on, you're the one who
likes double picks, right?
It was a day
Miyazu 3 Shiratori pair, so 3 is
white Tsurutomi is Tatsumi fixed
or reverse prime minister I do
n't
think so.  I didn't admit that,
so the guy who lost said to me, it
's okay, I can be a peer
.
Meh, thank you very much for listening Sometimes I'm a
corporate sperm Other times
I'm a badminton player A
superhero who opens up the future with a shuttlecock when he hits Yeah yeah yeah
car
What did you do this morning
?
Drinking
something like s Here is our ryotaro Yeah yeah yeah ha ha Ha Sagoshi Nayoro uni isn't there The
wind is also rocky
forgetting and flowing away 3 futanari through the
window It was Ariana who ended up in Roal
that day  I stopped to see it, so
there were four people in the rain Ah, a
detour washed away and you're unusual
That's am Otomi Harima
Nitan
That's right
[music]
me
pane
[music] It's
dawn and today I chose
the trail of excess yellow soil
[music]
What are you doing?
Hey, this is
badminton,
how about it?